good evening everyone welcome can you
all hear me OK in the back great my name
is Chris a little and I'm the managing
director of programs here at the
Stanford center for professional
development I'll give you a little bit
of background about our Center in a bit
but I wanted to make mention that during
the presentation either for those of you
who are in the room or the 30 or so
people that we have tuned in to the
livestream you can ask questions at our
Twitter site at Stanford CPD hashtag
SCPD grad you can ask questions live
obviously we'll have a Q&A session at
the end but you're welcome to you know
if you prefer to ask questions via our
twitter feed twitter feed you're welcome
to do that so with that I'd like to
welcome you our speakers tonight a
little bit about myself I've worked here
at Stanford since about two thousand one
and in the School of Engineering since
03 so it's really been my pleasure to
serve the school and Stanford in working
with folks like you working
professionals to help you further your
education with me today I have Michelle
Lucas rice who is our associate director
of graduate programs she's also been
with us since about two thousand eight
and Larry Lagerstrom who just joined the
team he was formerly the director of
online learning here in the School of
Engineering and he's joined us to
oversee our graduate program so they'll
be hearing more from them a little bit
later today so here's our agenda I'm
going to give you a little bit of
history about Stanford in the School of
Engineering we're going to talk about
how you engage in your online course a
little bit about your rights and your
responsibilities as well as six tips to
succeed for studying being a distance
student is really really challenging and
so we want to make sure we set you up
for success so Stanford University is
really interesting place how many of you
have attended an orientation before just
out of curiosity okay how many of you
have heard the story that the Stanford's
went to Harvard and beg them to let them
donate money to Harvard University has
anybody heard that story okay that story
is not true it's
completely false the Stanford's were
quite wealthy they were entrepreneurs
they leland stanford had founded the
Transcontinental Railroad and very sadly
their son Leland Stanford junior yes
that's the real name of Stanford
University Leland Stanford junior
University died of typhoid fever and out
of their grief they decided that they
wanted to found an institution to
educate the children of California in
doing that as good entrepreneurs and
venture capitalists do they did an East
Coast tour and they took a look at the
great institutions of the east so that
they could think about how they might
want to found an institution here at
Stanford and what was really interesting
is the founding of this institution from
the very beginning we had women in our
first graduating class and people of
color and it was a very very diverse
first class and that was really really
interesting and is in the roots of this
institution so I just want to say that
from an entrepreneurial standpoint and
from a diversity standpoint that those
are kind of founding principles of this
institution and a few other things is
that you know you'll find as you take
courses with us that Stanford has a bias
towards creating useful citizens which
is noted in the Charter as well so many
of the courses that you take our faculty
get very hands-on in terms of how they
think about the content and how they ask
you to practice the content so just a
couple of big picture ideas today the
university has seven schools you can see
them here you can see that roughly you
know we have more graduate students than
we have undergraduates but the number of
undergraduates is creeping up so we're
research institution our faculty are
some of the most productive faculty in
the world in terms of the research
dollars that are brought into this
institution compared to the number of
faculty that we have so that's one of
the things that makes us a top-tier
institution the School of Engineering
our engineering faculty are
extraordinarily productive we have of
all the
apartments in the school they're all
ranks in the top five and you can see
that CSE and mal ranked number one
currently we have alumni all over the
globe who have founded companies who are
CEOs and executives at companies of all
shapes and sizes and so that's kind of a
legacy here in the School of Engineering
one of the things about this building
this building was donated and named
after Jensen Huang who was an honors
cooperative student he was a part-time
master's degree student this auditorium
is named after the company that he
founded after he left and graduated
Nvidia so there's a legacy here if you
walk out into the lobby you'll see that
there's a Google server sitting there
that is the first Google server that was
sort of you'll see it's made out of
Legos which is kind of fun and
interesting to look at and then if you
walk down the hall you'll see the kind
of replica of the HP garage and so the
the founders of HP hewlett and packard
were graduate students of frederick
Turman who is the Dean of the School of
Engineering so there's a lot of history
and legacy there are a lot of
engineering luminaries on the walls in
this building so you can walk around and
there they all have their own
interesting stories so I encourage you
to do that while you're here today so
our center was actually founded by a
grant by Hewlett and Packard in 1954 to
help educate their engineers who had
become out of date with technology and
so it was really cutting-edge at the
time part time master's degree at a
distance the folks that HP came to
campus took courses here and then
homeworks were literally shuttled and
couriered back and forth and
examinations were couriered back and
forth to those students on the HP campus
today obviously we extend courses via
streaming video and other mechanisms
with massive open and online courses
well how many of you have taken a MOOC
how many of you have no idea what a MOOC
is okay that's interesting so anyway now
we service many many students around the
globe all different time zones we know
it's very challenging for you to pursue
courses online at a distance here are
some students that have been
very successful in doing so and we like
to highlight them we want to highlight
you someday so please let us know your
stories and let us know how it's going
throughout the year as I mentioned we
have many many graduates of the
University of their leaders and
companies around the world and here are
some examples many of you might be part
of these companies and we wanted to give
you a sense of the types of folks that
you might mingle with in your courses
while you're here another important
thing we consider you an extended part
of the Stanford community so I'd
encourage you to connect with each other
network today find out who's in your
courses with you take a moment to
connect to our social media that's an
opportunity for you to have
conversations about what's going on and
to connect back with us so we can hear
your stories maybe you'll be a jensen
Juan one day and and leave here and
found a company and so with that I'll
turn it over to michelle who's going to
talk on i miss one thing i do want to
make a point to introduce some of the
folks that you probably have interfaced
with virtually so Jonathan not man is
our director of student and client
services he oversees a team Chrissy Diaz
Cecilia canalis and Frank Maldonado who
will help you triage things like
enrolling in courses homeworks and
examinations frank is primarily
responsible for that and we wanted to
put faces to names so that you get an
opportunity to see who those who those
folks are they're all in the lobby so we
hope you connect with them while you're
here if you've exchanged emails with
them and then with that now I will turn
it over to michelle who's going to talk
a little bit about you know how the
quarter will work for you thanks
charissa ok well thanks so much for
joining us can you all hear me ok
excellent um so before I actually get
into the nuts and bolts of how you will
access courses and interact and
interface with the Stanford faculty and
SCPD team I want to get a show of hands
really quick how many of you are taking
courses through the nandu option lots of
you great and how many of you are taking
courses to the goners Cooperative
Program master's program
great excellent well we're thrilled to
have you all participating with us in
classes we're going to go ahead and talk
a little bit about the differences
between the pieces of the portfolio the
individual classes graduate certificates
and the master's degree program we're
also going to talk about how you login
to our website and access your class
videos because you'll be doing that next
week so I'm sure that that's what your
guys going to want to hear about and how
to find the the video content we're also
going to give you some resources for
technical support if something comes up
and you can't access your videos we want
to make sure that you know who to
contact and then finally some of the
information about sue net your stanford
university network ID which you will use
for a number of different sites and
resources here on campus and course
websites platforms that you'll be using
in partnership with your courses so
without further ado we'll go ahead and
get started so the non-degree option is
a part of our portfolio that allows non
matriculated students to take courses on
an individual basis you take the courses
for graduate credit and a grade you
complete all the same assignments
homework you take the same exams as the
students that are in the classroom on
campus you just are not matriculated in
a program the the benefit of the non
degree option program as many of you are
probably learning now is that it allows
you to kind of test drive the classes at
Stanford and see how it fits into your
life with work and family before you
decide to embark on a graduate
certificate or a credential or pursue a
terminal master's degree it allows you
to start out and see how the courses fit
into your life we're on a quarter system
and things move quickly so it's a good
way to be able to experience that for
the first time for those of you that
have taken a course and you guys realize
that you know I think I want to continue
and pursue a graduate certificate we
have roughly 28 30 graduate certificates
that are available online they are
completely online and they allow
students to complete coursework in a
focused area of the
curriculum to demonstrate depth of
knowledge in that area so they consisted
about three to five courses and the
courses are anywhere between three and
five units demonstrates some expertise
in areas like management science or
mining massive data sets and data
science so that is part of the non
degree option program but it's a little
bit more commitment that you can end up
with a Stanford credential when you
complete that the honors cooperative
program is carissa mentioned a little
bit ago is a master's degree it is not
an online master's degree it's a
part-time master's degree program so you
have the flexibility of taking courses
on campus or on line you are in the same
applicant pool as the graduate programs
here on campus it's a very competitive
pool you take the same degree programs
and at the end you leave with a Stanford
master's degree that is the same degree
as anyone here on the Stanford campus
you're part of the Stanford alumni and
it gives you all the same rights and
privileges as a regular master student
so for those of you that complete a
non-degree option course or potentially
a graduate certificate the nice thing
also is that if you start through the
non degree option and I'll talk about
this a little bit on the next slide
there's kind of a progression that can
happen you start out taking courses on
an individual basis to see how it fits
in with your life decide that you want
to pursue a graduate certificate and
then if you decide that you want to
pursue a degree you need to apply to the
degree program through the normal
admissions process and if you are
offered admission and accept you can
actually roll over 18 units that you
complete it as a non-degree option
student to your master's degree so you
actually start out about a third of the
way through the program when you start
through the non degree option and then
the master's degree is 45 units of
credit and you do have five years to
complete the master's degree through the
honors cooperative program the time
starts when you take your first class as
a math
your student not it doesn't count the
time that you spend in the certificate
or the non degree option program so this
is our website I'm sure that you've all
seen this site and are familiar with
this page as you've registered to attend
this orientation event but I want to
talk a little bit about how you're going
to access your class videos because
you're going to be doing that like I
said starting next Monday so you'll go
ahead and log into your my Stanford
connection account through the typical
fashion and when you get to your home
page there is a link right there on your
on your homepage for online videos
you'll go ahead and click on that and so
I know that we sometimes get questions
we do post class schedules on the
courses on our website and we get a lot
of questions about why is that aren't
these online the reason that we post the
class times on our website is because we
want you to know when the videos will be
available for you so if the class is a
monday wednesday friday class ten to
eleven fifty the videos will be up
online and available for you to view
within about two hours of the completion
of class on campus so by 2pm you should
be able to watch the class for that day
so we want to make sure that you are
aware that the videos will be up pretty
quickly and we expect you to follow
along with the class schedule and keep
up with all of the deadlines which I'll
talk about a little bit as well so you
will go ahead and access the videos on
that course home page when you click on
that link for the online videos you'll
be taken to the video player the videos
are I'm happy to say they are html5
compliant so they can be downloaded and
watched offline for those of you that
may be travel with work which is great
and they're also archived in the video
player in reverse chronological order so
you will have the most recent video up
on top but the videos will be stacked
historically so that you can go back and
refer to those videos as the quarter
progresses I'll talk a little bit more
about the actual player in a moment but
you can access streaming live excuse me
not live streaming at the two-hour time
mark or you can go ahead and download it
in low or high resolution and watch it
later offline
you can also advance the speed if you
wanted to go through the lectures a
little bit more quickly as you can
imagine lectures have different speeds
in which they speak and sometimes you
can speed it up to two point O and get
through the video and a much quicker
pace there are some that I would
fast-forward this gentleman up here on
the screen is not one of those for
anybody who's taken a CS course ki
Swartz is very energetic and talks quite
quickly I wish we had a slow down speed
for him we don't but so when you're
watching the videos be aware of on the
video player at the lower navbar to be
able to look for those features another
feature that we have are the bookmarks
and the clips and these are going to be
really important for you when you're
watching the videos of the class if
there's something that the instructor
says hey this is going to be on your
final so pay attention to this you can
bookmark that and put a note in there so
that you understand that this is
something you want to go back and visit
when you're reviewing for final exams
you can also if there's something that
the instructor is talking about that
maybe it's a formula or a concept that
is a little tricky and you're getting
stuck and you have questions you can
also make a clip and you can email that
to the instructor so if you have
questions you can say to him hey I'm
stuck on you know the 52 minute mark of
this date I need a little bit more help
with this concept can you go over this
with me or send it to the TAS and they
can go ahead and walk through with you
or set up a google hangout or something
so you can talk to them and work through
it so those are two features that are
going to be really helpful also with the
bookmark you can mark things privately
or take notes mark them privately or you
can share with the others that are
enrolled in that class as well so
something that those are two great tools
and then you can see on the right-hand
side of the video player where you can
go into the tab that has these things
that you've marked an archived so
anybody have any questions about that
okay excellent
if you have problems accessing your
video every once in a while there's a
firewall when somebody's trying to watch
the videos at work or maybe there was a
guest speaker in the class and we needed
them to sign a release so that we can
post the video online every once in a
while there will be a delay in the video
posting it's very infrequent but it does
happen if you are not able to access
your videos or you don't find them there
please don't monkey around trying to
figure out how to be able to fix it
reach out to us we have a very robust
team of technical experts that are
available to help you with any kind of
technical issues you have they can
likely resolve it in a matter of minutes
so please don't hesitate to reach out to
us and let us know if there's something
that is going on well we'll get on it
right away and make sure we resolve it
few quickly so each of you that is
enrolled in the course will have what's
called a stanford university network ID
this is a su net and this will be
referred to in lots of emails from us
and you'll need this to access a lot of
the portals that are used in conjunction
with your courses so a su net allows you
to access your Stanford account this is
not the same as your my Stanford
connection account you don't actually
need a su net to access your SCPD my
Stanford connection account but there is
a portal called access ax CSS and that
is a university portal for students and
faculty you'll find things they're like
your grades and you need to make sure
that you can log in with your soo net
and your password you have to
authenticate to be able to get into that
system so you'll use your soo net for
that if you're logging into a course
website a lot of courses will use my
coursework or other platforms Piazza you
see net you'll need a su net to be able
to access those as well and you'll also
as part of that soon at you'll have an
email account a Stanford email account
that you should all be aware of and I'll
tell you why in a moment but the su net
will also be your email address so my
name is Michelle rice my sous net could
be M rice and my email would be M rice
stanford edu so you're soon that's going
to be the key kind of how you integrated
Stanford one of the reasons that I
wanted to call out the email that you'll
have is because the university does send
out evaluations for the courses that
they use to be able to make sure that
courses are aligned to what is important
for the students to learn they want to
get feedback on the teaching team they
want to make sure that the course
materials are aligned with what was kind
of presented in the course description
so we want to make sure that you get
access to that evaluation because if you
submit it it also allows you to get your
grades earlier as well and so we want to
make sure for those of you that have
company pay and you need to do
reimbursement we want to make sure you
get your grades as quickly as possible
so please do check your Stanford email
regularly so that you know when those
come they usually are sent out two or
three weeks before the end of the
quarter so keep an eye out for that and
make sure you complete it and submit it
so the course websites like I mentioned
there is like my CC net there's also
course work which is the the largest one
that most courses use there's one called
novo ed which is a site that was
developed by Stanford faculty to host
team project work and it facilitates
teamwork so you'll go ahead and use this
along with the videos you'll access the
videos through our website and then
these other course websites is where
you'll find things like class materials
a class roster a lot of faculty will
have you submit homework on this site so
you're going to want to be able to be
familiar with the course website faculty
typically announced this in the first
lecture so you'll know which site you
guys will be using so please pay
attention to that it also has the
syllabus which you should be able to
access it has office hours the teaching
team information the names emails
contact information has office hours for
both faculty and the TAS so there's a
lot of information on the course website
you're going to be able to access that
you're going to want to be familiar with
so please do check that out early in the
hopefully the first day or so a lot of
courses also use different platforms to
be able to support the online community
so for what instance one of them is
Piazza it's a discussion forum platform
and so a lot of times TAS and faculty
will use these sites to be able to have
students asked questions and it's more
of a peer question platform where
students will ask questions and a lot of
times students will weigh in and they'll
respond to those questions and then the
things that there's themes starting to
bubble up about the court the questions
that people have those will kind of
surface up to the top and the faculty
and the teaching team will weigh in on
those as well so please make sure that
you're familiar with those again for
office hours and for problem sessions a
lot of faculty and staff are using now
things like Google hangout or WebEx or
zoom which allow you to have like a
video conferencing to be able to connect
with the teaching team so find out if
you're teaching team for your course
offers those to the students and a lot
of times even if they don't if you want
that asked for it and a lot of times
it's just as simple as setting up an
appointment to be able to connect with
you so please do voice that to your
teaching team so that they know what
what you'd like from them so one of the
things that we wanted to highlight is
that on our website under the programs
tab we do have student handbooks and
this is where we have a lot of our
policy information that you should
become familiar with has information
about tuition and grades it has policies
around dropping courses it has
information about resources like course
advisors libraries so it has a lot of
information you're going to want to
access throughout the quarter so we do
ask that you become familiar with those
handbooks so that you understand the
policies and the guidelines and it'll
anything you can use to be able to help
you navigate a little easier we do have
those resources available for you so I
want to talk a little bit about the
homework process how many of you are in
the class for the first time first time
student with us most of you okay
excellent so the homework in the exams
process is really important so I want to
spend a little time on this so a lot of
times the faculty will simply have you
submit homework through their course
website so for instance if you are
taking a course that is using course
work there is a designated upload where
you can put your homework right there
for the teaching team to collect and
grade if the teaching team asks you to
submit to them directly please do so we
don't want to become a barrier between
you and your teaching team but sometimes
they will want us to be able to manage
the homework process for you and in that
kind of a scenario we have a
distribution department that handles the
homework process and essentially what
you would do is email the homework to us
or I think I don't know those of you
that still have a fax machine can fax it
to us but most of them just email to us
and we'll go ahead and make sure that we
printed and distribute it to the
teaching team the same day or the next
morning so it's also if it comes to us
we do have the ability to date and time
stamp that and we keep it on file for a
year so if there's any question about oh
we never got this assignment it's not in
the gradebook we can pull that up for
you and make sure that we can resend it
so it's a good idea to keep us in the
loop on that process but again like if
you are taking a computer science course
and you have a huge algorithm that you
need to be able to submit by all means
work directly with the teaching team and
submit it in the format that their that
they're asking and through the medium
that they have for all of the other
students but we do have an
infrastructure in place for those of you
that are instructed to submit your
homework to SCPD so once we do receive
it like I said we will go ahead and
either print it and bring it to or we
will go ahead and forward it on to the
teaching team they will go ahead and
receive it and then they'll grade it
with all of the other student
assignments and then they'll go ahead
and leave it in a Dropbox for the
distribution Department to pick up and
then we will go get that bring it back
to SCPD offices scan it and then return
it to you so that you have their grade
and feedback on your assignments if you
find that you don't
receive an assignment back please reach
out to us right away and I ask that
because a lot of times when the teaching
teams are grading their grading as a
group and they've got you know a hundred
200 sometimes several hundred homework
assignments to grade and they yours may
get put in the box for the on-campus
students and if we need somebody to go
and find it and retrieve it and get it
back to you it's better that we know
sooner than later if you don't receive
your homework so that you can get that
feedback so that you can use that for
your next assignment so please if you
ever wonder err on the side of caution
and reach out to us so that we can look
into it the exam process so as many of
you are probably already aware and
hopefully most of you have already
appointed SCPD students are required to
have an exam monitor for every course
that they take the reason is because
taking courses online we need to
preserve the integrity of the exam and
make sure that students have an
appropriate space and time to be able to
take exams so we ask all students to
appoint someone in this role within the
first week or ten days of the quarter
with that gives us time to verify that
person and I'll talk about who can and
cannot be an exam monitor in a second
but we need to verify who they are what
their role is make sure it's not your
mom or your girlfriend but we want to
make sure that it's somebody that is
either an HR representative at your
company if you work for yourself or you
have your own company and you don't have
someone in this role then we can go
ahead and have an exam proctoring or an
exam monitor appointed to you through a
proctoring service you can also use
someone who is at a public library you
can also have someone Proctor the exam
who is at another institution so there's
lots of options that you guys can use
but everyone has to have an exam monitor
on file even if you're planning to come
to campus for the exams you need to have
one on file just because who knows you
might be driving to campus and get a
flat tire and you don't make it and we
need to make sure that we can send it to
some
one who can give it to you so please do
make sure that that's taken care of
something that we actually have started
doing just I think last summer is
students who do not have a monitor
appointed by I believe it's the drop
deadline we actually disabled their
videos until they get someone appointed
so we don't want there to be any
interruption in your video access so
please do make sure that you get that
taken care out it's a really important
part of our process and it's also
required by the Western Association of
schools and colleges wasc their
accreditation body requires that we have
those on file for all students taking
remote education so once you have the
exam monitor appointed what happens then
is the faculty and teaching teams will
get us the exams no less than a day or
two before the exam is supposed to be
SAT and we will go ahead and forward
that out to your monitor that's a on
file the exam along with any guidelines
or instructions materials you can or
cannot use the length of time that you
had to complete the exam and they will
make sure that you have that time and
space to be able to complete your exam
according to the guidelines of the
teaching team once you have finished
taking your exam you will turn that back
to your monitor who will sign off that
this was completed according to the
Stanford honor code and they will return
that exam to us and we will forward that
to the teaching team once the teaching
team receives it they will go ahead and
grade it with all the rest of their
exams and they will return it to us will
scan it and return it to the students if
the teaching team elects to return exams
sometimes faculty do not return final
exams so they'll let you know in on an
individual class basis if they will be
returning your exam but that's what the
process is does anyone have any
questions about the exam process excuse
me how does taking the exam into class
which work how does taken the examined
class work so um it really depends on
the faculty what their policy is about
taking exams on campus but I'm glad you
asked it because it's something that's
good to know so uh typically if you live
within 50 miles
the Stanford campus you are encouraged
to come and sit in the class and take
the exam with your peers if you are
unable to do so then you can take it
remotely at your place of work or one of
the other proctoring options and we'll
go ahead and make sure that they have
that in advance at the time that you're
supposed to sit for it but some faculty
they are hard and fast about making sure
that people that are within 50 miles are
here on campus so ask them about that a
lot of times they'll mention that in the
beginning of the class because they know
that there are SDPD students that are
taking the classes but if you are able
to I think it's great to be able to show
up and take it with the class here on
campus and I saw a question over here as
well I guess Wow take it of causing that
I have a final have anything that they
only have to project in assignments and
stuff so it didn't eat something so
we're actually working on that process
right now that's another very good
question so for those that are remote
the question was if there is no final
exam do I still need to do this so
historically the answer has been yes you
still need to have one on file simply
because we are required to have this for
all of our students we're looking at
ways that we can be a little bit more
flexible with that because we realize
that there are lots of scenarios one of
them being that there's a project that
you are going to be doing or a
presentation that you're going to be
giving or perhaps there's a take-home
exam that is open book and you I mean so
there's a lot of scenarios that would
kind of make this seem silly for now the
answer is yes we do need that to be
completed and we are working on a way to
make it a little bit less burdensome for
the students yes two questions the first
is for this quarter when is the exam
period what's up it is I want to say
like the 11th or 12th through the 15th
or 16th I'm not a hundred percent of the
dates but I can certainly look into that
and let you know before the end of the
networking session tonight okay the
second question is if for work or for
for related purposes link so you have to
present to the conference or something
in fact conflicts with your exam
schedule how does how do you work around
that that's a great question so the
question is what if you have a conflict
and you're unable to take the exam when
it's happening so one other thing that
I'll say about when the final exams are
is if you go to the calendar on our
website which I think Larry will show
you how to find it in a moment we do
have the final exam dates on that
calendar and I could still have a few by
the end of this session tonight but most
importantly if you do have a conflict
with the exam so the exam dates are
known like a year in advance so they are
already posted on the Stanford site
they're posted on our site so there
should be no ambiguity about win exams
are happening so you need to plan for
them and I would we've had students that
have had to drop classes because they
would be unavailable and the faculty
would not allow leniency it really
depends on the instructor so what I
would suggest is if there is a chance
that you will not be available for your
final exam reach out to your instructor
and do it early and let them know there
are faculty that will give you a day
maybe two leniency of when to do it but
you need to realize that they can't give
it too early because they need to
protect the integrity of the exam and
because of grading and entering grades
into the database at Stanford they can't
give it to delayed so there's usually if
there is any flexibility it's usually a
day or two max and so you would need to
be able to reach out and ask them that
early to be able to find out if that
will be available to you but typically
we tell students work is not an excuse
to miss deadlines and if you're going to
miss a deadline the final exams is not
the one to miss so did you want to say
something process december seven to the
11th thanks guys
okay any other questions I saw that one
was there I guess yeah this is kind of
build up with a question you have more
than one exam honor y'all gonna work in
different offices yes in fact what we
typically ask is to have people appoint
a primary exam monitor and then a
secondary exam monitor for precisely
that reason or maybe your exam are that
your point is sick or is out of the
office for whatever reason it's good to
have a backup just in case absolutely
yeah for sure yes something about
verification for example hours what is
that so essentially when students
appoint an exam monitor to serve for
their exams we are required to verify
that that person is who they who you say
they are which means that we reach out
to them we have them confirm their name
their title their role to make sure that
it's not Joe in the cubicle next door
and not really your manager so we just
need to make sure that they are who they
say they are because we actually asked
them to adhere to the Stanford honor
code as well because they are going to
be administering this exam for you so we
just need to make sure and and for
reasons more for like just not knowing
than anything else sometimes we find out
that like oh it's actually not somebody
that would qualify for that role so we
need to be able to reach out to the
students I hey you know what there there
appear and not a manager so we just need
to make sure that you appoint someone
else and so it gives you by doing it by
the deadline that we set it allows us to
verify you can look around we probably
have I think we get last count with 700
people that are enrolled in classes this
autumn through SCPD so we have a lot of
exam monitors to verify and if we need
to reach out to the student we want to
have time to do that so that you can
make a change and update that so there's
a lot of pieces in the puzzle and we
want to make sure that that happens
before you have a midterm perhaps so I'm
gonna go what's the timeline for the
midterm examination for this awesome
clutter so the midterms typically happen
about week 5
I'm going to move forward and we're
going to be out in the networking event
afterwards so I'm happy to take any
other questions about exams this is a
this is a hot topic that I know there's
always lots of questions but I I need to
really move it along and now i'm going
to hand it off to later thanks thanks
Michelle okay and everyone hear me my
mic up I guess just one of the thing on
midterm exams I midterm week five about
halfway through but it depends on the
course you may have a midterm week three
you may have a midterm week seven or
even week eight so just as the final
exam schedule is set almost a year in
advance so you need to be checking that
during the first week of classes or even
before this week check the syllabus for
your course see when those midterms
might be scheduled so you can match it
up with your your own schedule so I have
the great privilege here of talking a
little bit more about your rights and
responsibilities we won't dwell too long
on these things many of you probably
have already realized that we have the
slides as a handout in your packet along
with all the other information so you'll
have time later to to really study it if
you like Michelle mentioned earlier the
academic calendar there are different
ways to find it on the Stanford website
you can certainly find it on our SCPD
website by going to admissions maybe not
the the most obvious thing to click to
find the calendar but admissions and
then there's a link over here r academic
calendar and then you can go month by
month there's also some filtering here
you can do two for academic deadlines or
holidays webinars and so on and so forth
so you have some options there in terms
of how you actually display the calendar
but make sure you're glancing that
occasionally so you get a sense of where
you are and what's going on important
deadlines we've already been talking
about some of those deadlines the first
day of instruction is an important
deadline for enrollment and tuition
purposes if you are not having your
company reimbursed tuition then you need
to have your tuition paid by the first
day of instruction and hoops adding a
rip soul on here it
adding or dropping courses technically
the deadline to add or drop of course is
the end of week three in the quarter
practically however for adding courses
it's usually the first week because by
the by the second week or third week in
a 10-week order too much has just gone
on to try to catch up even though
technically you can add the course and
the instructor the professor also has
some say some of them will not allow
students to add say after the end of
week two even though technically you
could do it after the week three just
because they know from past experience
that students will not do well if they
add to too late for dropping courses
it's the end of week three if you drop a
course it disappears completely from
your record as long as you do it by the
end of week 3 5 p.m. pacific time so for
those of you in different time zones
take take note of that if for some
reason you forget about it and don't do
it until the monday after it's really
sort of a too bad type of situation ok
these deadlines are very strict very
very difficult to get exceptions to to
the deadline so again make sure you know
what the calendar is and and what's
going on grading basis letter grade
versus credit no credit in general you
will want to take things for letter
grades especially if you're interested
perhaps in a certificate down the line
and or of course a master's degree the
grading basis can actually be changed
back and forth as many times as you want
up until the end of week 8 of the
quarter so you do have some time to
think about a bit again in general for
for all of you the preferred option or
recommend option really is to do a
letter grade the withdrawal deadline is
also the end of of week eight in the
quarter sometimes life happens maybe you
get really sick family emergency or
whatever and you're not able to to
complete the course and it's after the
drop deadline you have any options and
the answer is yes it's a withdrawal
option the course will stay on your
transcript it doesn't count against you
in terms of grades or anything although
you'll get a w notation just for
withdrawal I've advice excuse me many
stood
over the years and sometimes I say
excuse me that that W stands for wisdom
excuse me in other words you made a wise
choice at that time if however something
like that happens come and talk to us
first okay so we can work through the
options with you and see what's going on
and then of course deadlines for
assignments and exams you'll find that
on your course website and course
syllabus and as Michelle mentioned
traveler workload is not a reason for an
exception so you want to plan ahead in
these things please involve us if things
like that happen of course evaluations
actually this was already mentioned by
Michelle in terms of the end of quarter
evaluation for for Stanford but we also
have our SCPD midterm evaluation you'll
get an email a link via email around
about week five and it allows us to get
some feedback we share it with the
teaching team and sometimes they can
make mid-course Corrections in terms of
what's going on in the course if
necessary and then the university end of
quarter evaluation that that Michelle
already mentioned again you'll want to
do this if for no other reason you'll
get your grades faster if you do not do
the end of quarter evaluation usually
have to wait about two weeks before you
can can see your grades and you can see
there's an faq site for more information
about that Stanford honor code has also
been mentioned a couple times already it
was actually established at the request
of students all the way back in nineteen
twenty one and the reason was they want
to make sure that a Stanford degree a
Stanford credential meant something they
didn't want to get the reputation that
you can come to to Stanford and there's
a lot of academic misconduct going on so
that if you take a course and you work
hard but somebody looks at that
credential of that grade and says well
yeah I'm not so sure about that Stanford
has this reputation for for a lot of
shenanigans and things like that going
on and so basically you actually have a
handout a little brochure in your packet
that talks about the Stanford honor code
but if you want to sum it up it's all
students must come
thrown work now sometimes you do have
projects collaborative projects you work
together and the faculty will define the
guidelines in terms of how that that
works but in terms of citing material
quoting material if you're writing a
paper or doing some sort of report and
so on and so forth you need to make sure
you adhere to here to those standards so
that your grade your degree your
credential actually means something out
there in the world there's an office of
community standards that handles all
disciplinary action and hopefully none
of you will ever have to deal with them
but it's we try to make it a very fair
process but there is a process that that
you have to go through if that is the
case fine line this section your rights
and privacy there's something called
FERPA you may hear that term around here
occasionally Family Education rights and
Privacy Act it is a federal a bit of
legislation essentially it gives its
they're fairly significant rules and
regulations in terms of how your
information can be released information
that Stanford keeps and so on and so
forth we can release information to
Stanford faculty and staff who need it
that doesn't mean we can release say
your grades to any factly they have to
have a reason for seeing your grades for
examples obviously faculty in the course
or university staff mean you have a need
to know we cannot though make public or
otherwise release information without
your your consent and this especially
applies if you are in a situation where
your company is is paying for all or
some of your tuition to release
information to them such as your grade
so they can process a payment or
whatever you need to let us know that
you give us permission to to do that and
that just it's part of the process of
when you you know pay your tuition and
go through all that they'll be some sort
egg off there that says yes I have read
and understand this and I give my
permission okay common student
challenges if you just think about this
a lot of these are fairly obvious but
just learning Stanford systems any new
soft
we're system you can see you may have
several systems new systems in terms of
the Stanford system are sepd website
your course website just give yourself a
little time to learn how all those
things work it will become very familiar
fairly quickly accessing class resources
as well of course creating teams and
study groups when you're at a distance
can be a little bit more of a challenge
but with all the online tools and use
things like Piazza and so on and so
forth it is easier but just again don't
put things off to the last minute in
terms of connecting with with other
students times our differences for those
of you really at a distance again in
terms of deadlines the deadlines are
pacific standard time or pacific
daylight time whatever one we have to be
on at the moment so make sure you take
that into account getting help also your
teaching team there's instructor there
are teaching assistants they will have
resources online study groups sometimes
and things like that allowing you to to
get help to ask questions online but
they're not customer service
representatives okay they're there to
point you in the right direction not to
solve the problem for you and so it's
very helpful if you have a question to
try to identify where am I having
problems with this where am I stuck is
it a certain thing in the video is it
the problem itself I don't quite
understand what that means in terms of
the wording or I I got the first part
but I'm stuck at the second part if you
can sort of specify your question a
little bit more than the teaching team
can help you and point you in in the
right direction there so those are just
a few of the common student challenges
and we want to finish off now and give
you six success tips here and so the
first three number one commit to a
growth mindset commit to a growth
mindset what do we mean by that well
there's a professor here at Stanford
named Carol Dweck Carol Dweck dwe ck
professor psychology very well known in
her field and
she discovered a phenomenon that people
tend to fall into one of two camps on
various things and she called one cancer
of a growth mindset and the other camp a
fixed mindset and fixed mindset people
and by the way highly intelligent people
can be in either camp here so it doesn't
relate to that there may be some
genetics involved there maybe it's an
environment upbringing involved in
things like that but just by doing very
psychological tests they discovered sort
of these these two groups of people and
fix mindset people unconsciously for the
most part feel that your abilities are
fairly fixed your artistic ability
either have it or you don't athletic
ability either have it or you don't
intellectual ability either have it or
you don't doesn't mean that you can't
get a little bit better at things but
the idea is at a certain point you will
reach the limits of your ability growth
mindset people on the other hand think
that sure everybody it's not saying
everybody has the same mount Billy but
everybody has ability to get better at
something whether it's artistically
athletically intellectually and so on
and so forth and you say well that sort
of makes sense but what's very
interesting is that especially they've
done studies on highly intelligent
people like all of you like Stanford
students and things like that they've
tracked them through hard courses and
when that first midterm comes and a lot
of them c grades they've never seen
before c plus these things like that
they find that those who tend have a
growth mindset they can identify them
via you know various measures persevere
and move forward while those have a
fixed mindsets maybe unconsciously just
think you know maybe I've hit my limits
here maybe this course just isn't for me
or this course of study isn't for me and
so by the end of the course those who
start off of the growth mindset even
though in all other respects that are
similar to those with the so-called
fixed mindset end up doing about it one
grade better than the fixed mindset
people now we could go on and on about
this but let me just tell you one good
thing is that growth mindset versus
fixed mindset it's not fixed that beasts
or the fixed mindset view of growth
mindset right you have
or your don't write well no just by
learning about growth mindset a little
bit and reminding yourself about that
you can learn new things and you can
progress then can put you into a better
frame line and achievement and success
or correlated more with a growth mindset
than a fixed mindset and like I said
even very highly intelligent people can
have a fixed mindset in this way so that
when they get that bad grade they think
it's saying something deep about
themselves when really all it's saying
is it's a measure of how much they know
or their level of skill at that certain
point in time and they can always
increase that via a growth mindset I
have the Stanford logo up there and the
reason I have that there when you see
that you should remember the the growth
mindset because it's got the redwood
tree on it and for those of you in in
botany perhaps or whatever redwood seas
are very very small they turn into these
huge trees of course and even though of
course trees don't have growth mindset
or fixed mindset it can be a symbol of
the growth mindset there for you Durham
as a reminder another thing redwood
trees have by the way they have
resilience they don't have perseverance
and grip but in terms of their their
ability to be impervious to fire to some
extent they can overcome that so coming
out of a growth mindset we want you to
cultivate resilience cultivate
perseverance cultivate grit back there
have been a lot of studies recently on
exactly that you think grit sort of a
down-home term and no sense it actually
is a study in psychology now the study
of of grit we have a fantastic website
as Stanford's referenced in your your
notes resilience stanford.edu we have
videos they're very accomplished people
who are connected to Stanford professors
Supreme Court justices CEOs the founder
of pandora music and radio and they talk
about how they had to go through some
really tough times to get to where they
are now and so they can serve as an
inspiration for a growth mindset and for
resilience there as well so it will be a
challenge
in your courses at certain points
cultivate resilience for that also
remember that knowledge is constructed
not received this is especially
important for online courses because in
many cases you're watching videos right
what do we do we watch online videos we
sort of passively watch them maybe
rewind them a little bit things like
that for knowledge it's almost like
building a skyscraper you've got to
actually lay those floors down and then
you construct things on at you say how
does this fit in with that where does
this go and so on and so forth so it's
not just a pass a receptive process you
have to actively engage with with
material and and sort of generate over
time experts are those who generate sort
of a skyscraper of knowledge a mental
schema as it were of everything and how
it all fits together so knowledge is
constructed not not received number four
practice deep practice they've got some
weights there how do you get stronger
well you lift weights now the brain is
not a muscle of course but the analogy
is correct you can't multitask and get
deep practice out of that you have to
really engage with the material as I
said you have to you know set aside some
time to really dig into the material and
wrestle with it to become mentally
stronger and again we have in the
handout talks a little bit more about
that I really that that period of deep
focus and attention now also you can
take advantage of what you might call
Micro learning opportunities when you're
waiting in line or whatever look at that
problem that's good beyond the problems
that you know doing a few days just
glance at it think about a little bit or
whatever and so take an edge of those as
well but of course if you really want to
get into the material you're going to
have to set aside some good good time
and focus and attention study smart I
won't go into this we have a number of
tips on the handout in your your packet
just to not just study harder you may
need to do that but to use better
techniques so that you do have that
focus and attention for the time periods
you you need to do that and then finally
for our success tips embrace the
challenge embrace the challenge a couple
years ago I was had the honor of
teaching a MOOC a massive online open
course on Einstein and the special
theory of relativity and had a number of
quotes that I sprinkled throughout the
course from Einstein this is one of my
my favorite ones the struggle to
understand while performing creative and
open-minded intellectual work is what in
Noble's humans and their riches our
nature so certainly in the courses
you'll be taking here at Stanford you'll
be getting a lot of practical knowledge
and experience for your career for your
work either current work or our future
work but also as you're doing that as
you're embracing the struggle you'll be
performing creative intellectual work
and that's an ennobling and enriching
process so don't forget about that in
the midst of the challenge as as well so
those are six success tips again you'll
have much find much more information in
the handout i encourage you to to look
at that and happy discuss it further
with you afterwards out in the fourier
there and just remind you ok the in fact
put this up on your wall or something
similar to it stanford logo right means
commit to a growth mindset cultivate
resilience knowledge is constructed not
just passively received practice deep
practice the weightlifting analogy to
get into it study smart and of course
embrace the the challenge there so now
we're on to our question session and i
will turn it back to a michelle for a
few final thoughts and then we'll get to
that thanks Larry okay so I we're
wrapping up the presentation if anyone
has any questions I would be happy to
take them now yes what's the
policy the parking policy the parking
policy
is that it's free after 4pm if you are
on campus for a seminar or something
after four o'clock then you don't have
to worry about parking you can park
without a permit otherwise permits are
required there are some metered parking
in the different parking garages that
are located throughout campus and so if
you are taking courses to the non-degree
option you are required to buy parking
permits or use the meters before 4pm I
think it's like six a.m. to four p.m.
does that help will also say that
parking the parking attendants are very
very diligent and the tickets are
expensive so I encourage you to not pay
power-play parking lot roulette actually
pay for parking because it'll be much
less expensive than the ticket that
you'll get
so question from Twitter how do I find
and collaborate with s CBD students who
enrolled in the same courses mean one of
the things that we actually started
doing in the last couple of quarters is
trying to facilitate some team building
and peer support in the classrooms for
the students that are enrolled through
SCPD if this is something that you are
interested in doing and I'm sure I'm
going to get a ton of emails now and
please reach out to me and let me know
and I will go ahead one of the things as
Larry and mentioned with the FERPA act
is that we need to make sure that we
protect the privacy of the students
which includes emails names and that
kind of personal information so if there
is a desire to connect with students
that are in your class to be able to
form study groups or project teams
please let me know I will have to reach
out to all of the students in that class
through SCPD it will not be with the
on-campus students that will be with the
SCPD cohort and I need to get explicit
permission from each student to share
their information and essentially all
that I ask for is their first and last
name their email address and the city of
their location just four times own
purposes and if there's somebody that's
close by that you can go ahead and
understand who's near to you once i get
that i usually give about 48 hours
turnaround time and once i receive
approvals i send it out to the class and
then you can go ahead and kind of self
connect but we have started doing that
over the last couple of quarters and so
in some courses it doesn't really make
sense other courses they are project
courses and the faculty will work to be
able to facilitate teams and project
work and so the teaching team may
actually facilitate this for me so find
out what kind of course you're going to
be in and what the faculty offers and if
it's not something that's done by the
teaching team I'm happy to go ahead and
help that help with that effort okay
another question how can we move from
graduate certificate programs to a
master's
uh so if you are interested in pursuing
a master's degree and you've taken a
number of courses through the honor or
through the non degree option program
you would need to apply to the master's
program through the typical admissions
process which means you need to go
through the Graduate Admissions site you
need to be able to submit a completed
application you need to be able to which
includes a statement of purpose you need
to have letters of recommendation you
need to very importantly take your GRE
and submit your scores and so there is
the normal admissions process it's very
competitive for all of the departments
but you would go ahead and follow that
you'll be considered in the same
applicant pool as the students that are
interested in attending the graduate
program here on the Stanford campus and
if you decide to accept an offer of
admission at that point you would elect
to participate through the honors
cooperative program if you wanted to
continue in your career and then you can
go ahead and do it on a part-time basis
otherwise if you're if you're offered
admission you can certainly elect to
come on campus and do a full-time
program but it definitely goes to the
office of graduate admissions yes did
you get a question the back in the
Masters of electrical engineering
program for example you offer so certain
seminars that do not have a letter grade
so I do not understand how is the
trading pieces you know how could it be
of concern when you know there are 77
out there often which so the question is
about grading when you're taking
seminars so there's a pretty simple
answer we do not include any seminars
and graduate certificates and in order
to participate in a graduate certificate
you have to take courses for a letter
grade to contribute it to the
certificate if you're in a degree
program there's a certain number of
courses that you can take for credit and
there's a certain number of units that
you need to take it in seminars so it's
very different for the degree program as
opposed to the certificate or the non
degree option program I should also
point out that many
the seminars are actually available
online at no fee you can access them
through your my Stanford connection
account they are typically put online
later in the day from the day that the
seminar is given and you don't have to
enroll unless you want credit for it but
they are widely available are there any
other questions yes so the question is
that the online library excuse me at the
library is open to online students who
are taking courses through SCPD and the
answer is yes kind of so you are able to
access libraries as a SCPD student you
are not allowed to check out material so
if you are local in the area as it looks
like most of you are probably all of you
are you would just go ahead and bring
your enrollment paperwork so that they
can see that you are a student in the
course and then you will go ahead and be
allowed to go into the library you can
use the materials and resources you can
photocopy things but you just won't be
able to take anything out but yes and
there are a couple of libraries that you
will have easy access to in the School
of Engineering and I believe that those
are also listed on the resources page in
your handout yes oh here's about how far
in advance the registration deadlines
open for reporters and so for example
this one I think was about six seven
weeks in advance
I'm sorry is that kind of the rule of
thumb for all courtroom so does that
change so we do open enrollment about
six weeks before classes begin we try to
close it the week before classes start
just so that we can make sure we have
everything squared away with all the
systems so that you can start off on the
right foot and we usually post the
courses online that will be offering for
that next quarter about four to six
weeks before we open enrollment so that
you can kind of go through and plan I
know that this is a little tricky for
those of you that are trying to plan a
year or two or three out it's very tough
to pinpoint the classes that will be
available online but I would say that it
rarely changes every once in a while
there will be a new course offered by
the department and we'll get it online
or there's a really hot topic that's
kind of developing and emerging and so
we'll get something online in that area
but the courses that are in a
certificate program we must offer online
because students are pursuing a program
and it has to be done at a distance so
you can pretty much bank on those
courses being available online unless
the department has decided not to offer
it for a year which occasionally does
happen not not very often with the
certificate program program but it's
pretty good rule of thumb to check
previous quarters we do have links on
our site so you can look at previous
quarter courses and that way you can
kind of at least plan out and then just
confirm when we actually post that next
quarters course is online yes so uh like
scientific journals that the campus is
subscribing to um that's a great
question and I don't know the answer to
that I would say that if there is a
scientific journal or some kind of an
article that you need to be able to
access for your class the faculty will
make sure that you have access to it but
generally speaking if it's available in
the libraries i would think yes but I I
would need to look into that and give
you a more accurate answer i'm not i'm
not confident in my answer so i would
want to i would want to circle back
around with you and confirm that yes it
access to video from horses awkward for
our quarters so the question is whether
there is access available to courses
from prior quarters and answer
no not at this time we offer the courses
online 24 hours a day seven days a week
during the active quarter but once the
quarter is completed we do remove the
courses from online because there they
are covered by the teach act and they're
only covered in the tuition based cohort
that's offered at that quarter and I
should also point out that because we do
allow students to download videos that
at the end of the quarter you need to
dispose of those videos you cannot keep
them on your machines and we do have you
sign off for that somewhere in your
account when you sign up with us yes
okay 10,000 sunglasses oh gosh I'm so
sorry I didn't hear you convince it's
okay to have a chance in some cases is
it okay to sit in two classes on campus
yeah um if you're in the 90 degree
option program the answer is no
unfortunately and the reason is because
I know there's a few people from
departments in the audience and they can
probably attest to this we schedule
classrooms according to the estimated
number of students that will be in the
classroom on campus which is
matriculated students and like any other
university classrooms are a hot
commodity here and so it's a it's a very
complex problem to be able to schedule
classes and it would be awful to
displace degree-seeking students with
students who are not matriculated that
are taking courses may be individual
courses and not part of a degree program
so while we would love to host students
that are in non-degree on campus we're
unable to do so because as I just
mentioned we have about 700 students
that are enrolled in the non degree
option program this quarter alone and we
don't want people the fire marshal would
probably come in harass us if we had
people sitting in the in the aisles of
the classroom so we need to be really
protective of the students that are
matriculated to be able to have them
have a seat in class so but if you're an
honors cooperative student I know there
was a couple of you in here then yes you
would be able to sit in on the class as
part of the matriculated student body
yes so I work with exams so with exams
we actually have a different scheduling
process
the question was how does the attendants
work with these final exams so when we
are scheduling final exams we actually
reach out to the department's a lot of
them need alternate seating to be able
to have the exams taken and so there are
time to reschedule two three four
classrooms to accommodate one class and
so there is a lot more flexibility in
those scenarios for exams I'm going to
take one more question and then I'm
going to have you guys go out network
because I don't want to cut too much
into your time yes in the back oh lucky
one we are the lucky one is there if
there any timeline at which you can
transfer from the you know transfer to
the full-time status once and you get to
a bar chain program so I mean Lexi I'm
beginning my Master's ok this autumn
quarter and one transition into
full-time is there a minimum timeline
when I can do that so there is paperwork
that you would need to submit to be able
to transfer to a full-time the question
was if I'm in a master's degree program
is there a time frame to be able to
transfer from part-time to full-time or
even from full-time to part-time and the
answer is yes there's paperwork there
are deadlines to be able to do that to
submit it it needs to happen in advance
of the start of the quarter and I would
encourage you to reach out to our
student services team to get the
specifics on that and they're out in the
lobby this evening so they can go ahead
and answer questions and before we
actually release you I there's a few
people that I want to just call out in
the audience because I want I want you
to know who they are so we have two of
our course advisors with us this evening
jobar soin is right here he's the
management science and engineering
course advisor so if you have questions
about content or courses or instructors
or you just want to talk to him and
network a little bit he's here and he'll
be in the lobby afterwards to be able to
chat with you we also have roshni Cooper
who is in the back here she's our
electrical engineering course advisor
and she is here is again to answer any
questions that you guys might have about
EE content we also have Emily Wang she
is in the admissions department of
electrical engineering and she'll be out
there with us as well we have Deborah
Gordon here in the back and she
ashley is with the Freeman spogli
Institute and she oversees the
international security graduate
certificate so if any of you are taking
courses in that program Deborah is the
authority on all things international
security at SCPD and so she's a great
resource to be able to reach out and
talk to i've probably missed some people
Steve Bagley thank you he is the
director of the biomedical informatics
program and so he is here to answer
questions for any of you that are taking
courses in biomedical informatics or
clinical informatics we also have Lori
Caudill she is the student services
manager and management science and
engineering she'll be out in the lobby
she's not i don't think in the
auditorium but she'll be out in the
lobby as well and then the folks that
have been speaking you'll see some folks
from SCPD that are wearing black shirts
the stage Stanford University on them
please don't be shy come up and talk to
us introduce yourself and ask us any
questions that you have and we're
thrilled you guys could join us we have
some food and some drinks out in the
lobby please enjoy thank you
you